all right everybody will welcome to the
fourth rational physics conference my
name is
dave robinson one quick announcement
before we begin one of the proponents of
the rational scientific method that goes
by the moniker monkey mind has written
some books and so if you're interested
in them you can buy them back there
after the conference whenever so and
just so you guys know all the proceeds
are going to the free Ross campaign and
I got a chance to speak to Lynn briefly
and she was really really thankful so
thank you for coming and thank you to
the speakers for coming here
the fourth rationale physics conference
is a continuation of a conference that
happens in Europe and the purpose of the
conference is to give people who have
criticisms of the mainstream or theories
of their own the chance to share those
ideas before an audience and the
conference has been put on by Bill Gates
every year and if you don't know who
Bill Gates is he is a critic of
relativity quantum mechanics and string
theory and he has his own theory called
thread theory when I first came across
thread theory about four or five years
ago I thought it was interesting but I
didn't really understand it until I dug
in and read the book several times and
at this point I think I'm pretty
confident I can say that this is one of
the most significant scientific
discoveries in a long time I think it's
a really big deal and people oftentimes
say well where's all his peer-reviewed
papers you know where's his Nobel Prize
and so on and so forth and you've tried
to publish papers but you've been sort
of ostracized turned away stonewalled
you know called the crank and a crackpot
a few times here and there and a while
back in one of the Facebook groups we
were kind of discussing this and
discussing maybe the futility of trying
to spread these ideas and you have some
other ideas which don't bode well for
the future of man and so I had to ask
you what's the point of putting on these
conferences now why do this why are you
came all the way up from Germany why
come all the way out here and I thought
your answer was really pretty inspiring
he said look Dave the only reason that
I'm coming all the way out to an
archipelago is to drink beer so
what that mean said this one's for you
bill ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Bill Gates I was gonna give up
introduction but I guess he beat me to
it
Dave so I don't need to explain much of
that the only thing I want to add to
what he said is that the rational
physics rational science group
criticizes the establishment but what do
we criticize we criticize that the
mathematics of it we say that
mathematics first has nothing to do with
physics mathematics has nothing to do
with science science is about explaining
not about describing math is a
descriptive language it can only
describe it I can tell you how fast
something running I can tell you how
fast what the acceleration of gravity is
but I cannot explain to you what gravity
is or how it does it's magic for this
there's only one way you have to try to
figure out what invisible object is
doing the mechanism and that's what I'm
gonna explain today I'm gonna do it with
black holes I chose the black hole
because the black hole is like the the
ingrown toenail the smoking gun of
relativity it's as irrational as it can
get if you can't get past the
irrationality of a black hole I'm
wasting my time today I should pack my
bags and leave if I can't make my case
today with a black hole I gotta leave I
have nothing more to offer okay I called
my presentation the Rope hypothesis
rationally explains dark matter black
hole and big bang and I'm gonna go
through four steps here
the first one is I'm gonna argue that
there is no such thing as a black hole
you read about black hole every week
that they discovered one that they saw
one that they prove that whatever and
I'm gonna argue that there's no such
thing as a black hole why he
you heard of impossible objects can you
got the tribe are you can't produce this
in three dimensions
you've got the Penrose staircase that
the the impossible cube you have all
these things which are known as
impossible objects they're irrational
objects and that's where the black hole
book belongs it's an irrational object
okay that's what I'm going to show today
then I'm gonna go in there and explain
phenomena that currently is attributed
to black holes and I'm gonna give you a
totally different scenario you're gonna
see with your own eyes a different
perspective now I haven't come here to
convince anyone I haven't come here to
persuade or recruit anyone I just want
to give you something that you can
compare and make your own decision
that's the way science should work we
should not just shove down your throats
a theory and say it's been proven we
have the truth no I explain you
understand we're done with science what
continues now is religion I'm gonna
explain phenomena attributed to black
holes then I'm going to explain a
phenomenon attributed to dark matter as
well and finally I'm going to argue
against another icon of relativity which
is the Big Bang I'm saying it never
happened there was no beginning to our
universe okay so on with the first one
there's no such thing as a black hole
what is a black hole what is the
definition of a black hole when you look
up the this term what are they talking
about that's the first one I'm gonna go
through and I'm gonna go through how
many dimensions a black hole has we're
gonna find out the black hole has many
dimensions what is a black hole made of
I think it's a rational question to ask
if it's a physical object what does it
made out of
have we ever discovered a black hole
have you ever seen one have we proven
black holes and I'm gonna get
testimonies official testimonies on that
and finally if we have not proven the
black hole and we have to conclude that
maybe the black hole is beyond human
understanding and we have to accept it
like we accept other religious things on
the basis of faith Authority or
whichever one you want okay so I'm with
a person what is a black hole well when
you do some research where you like
research you find out that the black
hole has essentially two definitions
there's two notions of a black hole
under one hand you have the black ball
and on the other one you have a region
of space or of space-time so you have
these two notions we have NASA treats it
like an object as a black ball and
here's the testimony this is this is
directly from these websites right black
hole a great amount of matter packed
into a very small area they're talking
about small non zero dimensional talking
about small think of a star ten times
more massive than the Sun squeezed into
a sphere they're talking about a sphere
and I tell you about zero dimensional
approximately the diameter of New York
City diameter again something right
greater than zero gravity is so strong
because matter has been squeezed into a
tiny space again all the representations
you're talking about something there's
something that has size diameter they're
talking about a black ball okay wolfram
physics treats it as an object space
com2 two nines they're only relatively
small you see it there and city size
range so again they're all talking about
something a little ball of some kind
the star shrinks and turns into a ball
not into nothing but into a ball and
then we have the other side where they
treat as a concept the region region of
space or of space-time depending on who
you talk to and Berkeley says it's a
region of space but the good one comes
from Max Planck Institute says a black
hole is not a tangible object making it
clear you're now talking about a ball
you're not talking about tangible object
but it's a region of space it says later
on says black holes themselves are not
solid objects they miss but they said
object it's not a solid object there's
nothing there okay so we have these two
notions now there's a difference between
a ball in a region now I know some of
you are not from this planet you know so
I'm gonna show you something that is
from our planet our planet is Earth and
this is the mysterious black ball okay
now black ball can you all see this yes
why can you see it
you can see it because you have light
reflecting to your eyes or if the ball
is emitting light to your eyes some
signal and you capture it with your eyes
you see it but before you can do that
there's got to be a precondition and the
precondition is the black ball has to
have shape if there's no shape here
there's nothing to reflect light to you
there's nothing for it to emit because
there's nothing here but here you can
see it now this is a region of space you
can see it here and between my two
fingers in fact I'll take my fingers out
so you can see it better you see
anything there
how can a region of space send you any
signal so you know this region of space
is not a physical object it's not the
same thing as a ball so these people
have two different notions and I
synthesized it here what does a region
look like have you ever seen a region
can't bring a region to you like I
brought the ball I can bring a chair I
can bring you a table tree Iraq I can't
bring you a region because the region is
always of something else I can talk to
you about the region of the ball but I
can't talk to you about region just
itself in fact I could do something else
I can
I can show you my hand I cut my hand off
of the wrist
I can show you my hand and I can talk to
you about the palm the palm is a region
of the hand I can talk oh so about a
palm but I have to cut the fingers so I
cut the fingers off I show you the palm
say this is a palm so far so good but if
I want to talk to you about the palm
being a region of the hand I got to show
the fingers back on because a region is
always of something else and now you
have the very funny conclusion because
of this these two these two notions
region versus ball we're and we're in
Mexico let's use a Mexican citizen we
take a Mexican citizen from the streets
we crush them we smash them we make them
but as small as possible and we turn
them into a region of Mexico sound
sounds like a plan that's what they're
doing they're taking a star they're
shrinking is here's a standalone object
and they're convenient Verta get into a
region of space-time what sense does
that make
right there they have first a
contradiction in the definitions and
second they draw these conclusions that
a standalone object becomes a region of
something else makes no sense whatsoever
okay how many dimensions does a black
hole have well one of the persons who
most worked on black holes originally
was Chandra Sekhar he was an Indian
student who went to Great Britain and he
became famous eventually got the Nobel
Prize because of his work on black holes
this was Chandrasekhar said there is a
limit to the repulsion that the
exclusion principle can provide when the
star got sufficiently dense the
repulsion caused by the exclusion
principle would be less than the
attraction of gravity friend rest'
Chandrasekhar calculated that a cold
star more than about one and a half
times the mass of the Sun would not be
able to support itself against its own
gravity it would collapse completely
Eddington who was his boss nixed that he
said no I'm gonna let you continue in
this line of work you thought it was
simply not possible that a star could
collapse to a
and this was the view of most scientists
in those days and Einstein himself wrote
a paper in which he claimed that stars
would not strength to zero size and then
Chandrasekhar wins the Nobel Prize and
he had shown that the exclusion
principle could not halt the collapse of
a star more massive than the
Chandrasekhar limit and that's in a
brief history of time by Stephen Hawking
so this is official this is the this is
the current thought so here we have a
star collapses to nothing to zero
dimensions okay here we have the BBC
they made a documentary in which another
rising star a Brian Green says something
different he says the black holes are
collapsed stars massive objects crushed
to a fraction of their original size now
this is not zero dimensional now they're
talking about fraction and size so again
we have these two versions which is
correct our does a star collapse all the
way or does it does it remain as a ball
at the end so he's representing the
black ball whereas the testimony just
now by Stephen Hawking is that it's it's
it's nothing it's zero dimensional so we
have zero that mention on three diamonds
so someone asked the question how many
dimensions does a singularity could have
and several of the mathematicians not
physicists gave answers I picked out two
because they address two separate issues
the first one said the concept of a
singularity is a mathematical concept
not a physics concept and this is funny
because we have constantly in fact I
think it have it here and the string
theory says a very clearly the language
of physics is mathematics so it's the
language of physics is mathematics here
they're saying something different
they're saying the concept of a
singularity belongs to mathematics it
does not belong to physics so we have a
contradiction they go around in circles
you say well how many dimensions there's
a black hole how they said X you say
well but that's mathematics
yeah it's mathematics got nothing to do
with physics and then they tell the
astronomers go look for it now they're
looking for something in the sky what do
I look for if if this is a mathematical
concept we have these contradictions
constantly over
/ and a second answer which I picked it
says if we think just in terms of space
its zero dimensional but in a space time
it is one dimensional because it exists
over a period of time so now you're
saying hold it black hole collapses to a
zero dimensional point nothing right and
that's what you get on the 3d space side
right head-on view you see nothing zero
damage so what are you gonna see but
then if you see this in time and you see
a movie this zero dimensional point
traces a one-dimensional line which
comes out at the other side in another
universe as a zero dimensional entrance
now how many of you try to enter a zero
dimensional entrance ever in your life
have you ever tried to crawl through a
one dimensional line this belongs
totally in mathematics what does this
have to do with physics it has nothing
to do with physics but they go around
and around and around how many
dimensions does a black hole has I can
tell you right now it has zero
dimensional if you're talking about
space right right there it says so it
has one dimension if you talk about
space-time it has two dimensions if you
take a ball and squeeze it down to a
like if you project it on to a
two-dimensional platform and it has
three dimensions if you're going to look
for it with your telescope so how many
diamonds it has it has zero one two and
three there's your answer
they covered every base Lewis Leonard
and Franz Pretorius these guys published
the paper saying we showed this is a
peer-reviewed paper this is official the
black hole's radius is zero very clear
there's no radius there's nothing there
that's not what they draw look what they
drew they talked about I hope all of you
can see that black dot in the center
that's 2-dimensional at least it's got
width and height and and that's a
representation of a three-dimensional
ball so we have three dimensions two
dimensions and these guys are telling
you it's zero dimensional so which is
and and that's just the dot in the
center if you talk about the event
horizon which is the so-called limit the
region of influence of a black hole now
you're talking about at least 2d and 3d
so what they draw physics has nothing to
do with what they publish which is math
a published math and then they talked
and then they draw or illustrate physics
two different things and then again
someone here says the radius of a event
horizon increases as the mass of the
black hole increases now we're talking
about radius we're talking about size
again so they go back and forth so
what's the problem with all this well
the problem is that in physics when they
want to talk physics when they want the
common man who doesn't know anything
about mathematics what these guys are
referring to they say look that's a
black hole and everybody can relate to
him he says yeah I understand what they
got there it's some kind of tornado and
it's swallow stuff yeah I understand it
perfectly well but that's not what they
publish this is what they publish when
you look at the papers that they
published in the peer-reviewed journals
they talk about zero dimensionality they
put their equations there has nothing to
do with what they show the public so we
don't know how many dimensions have but
in fact we do they have zero one two and
three because they covered every base
you can you can't challenge this any
more
what are black holes made of that
question was asked of these four gurus
of physics I call them mathematicians
because they do everything with magic
Michio Kaku we just shrugged
Larry Krauss also shrugged he didn't
know any stronger he's from Harvard
professor from Harvard says okay already
you've asked me a question I can't
answer and max Terra or another rising
star so we don't really know what's
going on these were the official
responses now there's there's a problem
here because these are college
professors these guys studied at least
10 years in the Universities they have
PhDs okay and now they tell you well we
don't know what a whole black hole is
made up what do you mean you don't know
what a black hole is made of let me show
you what a black hole is made of black
hole is a region of space that has much
mass concentrated in it like whole is
all mass and no body it's very simple
black hole has mass why didn't they
answer that question they should have
said oops made out of mass and then
maybe they opened up a can of worms if
they said that because if they say look
it's made out of mass and you say well
what do you mean it's made out of mass
well what really is that and here's the
problem the note here theorem says all
black hole solutions can be completely
characterized by only three
parameters mass electric charge and
angular momentum and the Wikipedia
clarifies that the simplest static black
holes have mass but neither electric
charge nor angular momentum so no matter
what black hole you deal with it has
mass some have angular momentum and
charge some don't but all of them have
mass why didn't they answer that
question these [ __ ] professors I'll tell
you why mass is the quantity of matter
of an object or it's a measure of the
quantity of matter that's what you learn
in high school or college but the black
hole's crush matter out of existence
there is no matter in a black hole which
is the definition of mass the quantity
of matter so we have a circular
definition we have a black hole is made
out of mass mass is the quantity of
matter but a black hole crushes matter
out of existence so what are we have in
the end we ended up where we started
zero we have nothing so what do we have
do we have a ball do we have zero that
mental singularity are we talking
physics are we talking math this is the
problem but if you think that's the end
of it no there's one more step here are
these other two gurus John Wheeler and
Edward Taylor Nature does not offer us
any concept as the amount of matter
history has trucked down every proposal
to define such a term even if we could
count the number of atoms or by any
other counting method try to evaluate
amount of matter that number would not
equal mass mass is not the quantity of
matter they have no clue what mass is
they they don't have a definition so
after we went around in circles we find
out that mass is really not the quantity
of matter so we have several problems
here we have first two definitions we
have the region and the ball then we
don't know how many dimensions that had
in fact has all the dimensions because
they covered every base what are you
talking about you talking about space
got one dimension are you talking about
space now it's zero damage so you don't
know what are they talking about and
then they say you know they go around
this circles and tell you that you know
a black hole is made out of mass mass is
the quantity of matter matters crushed
out of existence what have we learned
what is a black hole this is your
rationality oh by
and they put it out as proof okay let's
find out proof how do we stand on proof
have you ever seen a black hole they ask
these same people they say no no I
caught him in a moment they say no no
one has ever seen a black hole directly
so how did they prove it
I mean it's proven it's a fact we see it
every day in in the popularization
magazines
and now they're telling you we've never
seen a black hole well hold it just 10
days ago 10 days ago
what 11th of February big news we had
the LIGO some people cut and legal LIGO
they this is a group that for many years
it's a 1990s they've been looking for
gravitational waves they finally found
two black holes that came together and
that admitted the gravitational waves
that we proven it well we proven it
we're the first these observations
demonstrate the existence of binary
stellar black mass black hole systems
this is the first observation of a
binary black hole merger and immediately
someone in the Wikipedia put it o 11th
of February 2016 the first ever direct
detection of black holes was announced
by the LIGO collaboration well these
people are a touch we've we've been
proving black holes at least since 1988
and I brought proof this is from Stephen
Hawking's book a brief history of time
1988 I have done a lot of work on black
holes and it would all be wasted if it
turned out that black holes do not exist
very powerful reasons for making them
exist in fact Lee had a bet with another
college professor his name is Kip Thorne
and he said look if Cygnus x1 turns out
to be a black hole I'm gonna buy you
what was it when you're sufficient to
Penthouse magazine and he finally said I
had to concede the bet because all the
evidence shows that Cygnus x1 is a black
hole what else could it be and he adds
we also now have evidence for several
other black holes in system like Cygnus
x1 in our galaxy in in two neighboring
galaxies called a mag aligning clouds so
they have all this evidence and now they
say oh we've discovered it for the first
we've been discovering for a long time
in fact I'll show you more evidence
physics world this is 2011 famous black
hole confirmed after 40 years another
one this is 2012 January 2012 the very
first black hole ever discovered was
discovered at U of T November 2012
scientists baffled by huge by cold
discovered in tiny gouge they've been
discovering black holes every month the
first one always the first one monster
black hole's spin revealed for first
time so what are these people talking
about what do you mean the first one
they had to give jobs to LIGO because
these people hadn't discovered anything
in 25 years they spent 600 million
dollars they didn't discover anything
and now at the hundred year anniversary
of Einstein they said we finally
discovered gravitational waves and
everybody pulled out the champagne
bottles among them Stephen Hawking he he
was given an interview he gave an
interview and he said oh this is a great
fine we finally discovered black holes
what do you mean you've always
discovered black holes and how can he
say he discovered black holes if he's
never seen one but has Stephen Hawking
looked through the scope and seen
something no someone else did
so he's taking their testimony and
putting it as his he's not an expert
witness in this he's never seen a black
hole in his life why should I trust his
word has he ever seen one can he bring
me a black hole can he draw a black hole
zero dimensional singularity he's never
seen a black hole so he's not an expert
witness an astronomer might be able to
tell me yeah I've seen one okay but not
Stephen Hockey what are they doing
they're using his authority to convince
you the part oh if Stephen Hawking says
so it's it's law he's not an expert
witness in this trial he should be
called to trial so they ask the
astrophysicists at NASA who was the
first person to discover a black hole
and answer black holes cannot be
observed directly and therefore cannot
be discovered they only look at it
through indirect evidence what does this
mean it means they're not proving
anything they're making an assumption
let's say let's assume there's a black
hole that black holes exist we see
something what could cause it it
must be a black hole that's an
assumption that's a lot of proof and
they're turning their assumptions and
approves into facts that's what they're
doing here what to convince the public
to say look we know what we're doing but
they can't define it they can't tell you
how many dimensions that but they've
seen and they proven it we got a problem
there's a contradiction there it's a
logical contradiction and here they tell
you how they discover black holes and
again it shows you that it's done
indirectly the way astronomers and
astrophysicists in a stern astronomical
observations is to look for light from
ionized dust and gas being sucked into
something so fast that it could only be
a black hole again it's a Sun in
Assumption which they are turning into
fact but now I got a problem with this
what do you mean dust being sucked in
and I get the light how can I get the
light if it's sucked in I thought a
black hole was black because it's sucked
in everything in its vicinity and
nothing was able to reach my eyes so we
had a problem how did they do this well
it turns out that when when they came
out with this Chandrasekhar limit they
said look you know black hole swallows
everything in its zero dimensions for
the astronomer said well we're out of a
job what do we look for and say we gotta
get these guys something to do or
they're all gonna we're gonna set all
the observatories down so they came up
with Hawking radiation
what is Hawking radiation this is a
quantum mechanics mechanism vacuum
fluctuations caused a particle
antiparticle pair to appear close to the
event horizon of a black hole one of the
pair falls into the black hole while the
other escapes to an outside observer it
would appear that the black hole has
just emitted a particle so we have to
understand what they're saying here
they're saying space is made out of
particles you take a particle and an
anti particle you put them together and
you end up with nothing take a ball a
black ball on a white ball you'll put
them together and you end up with no
ball that's what they're saying
okay that's space space can do the
opposite it can break apart the two and
you have a particle and an anti particle
a white ball in this case a blue ball
and a red ball right
the blue ball falls in it doesn't matter
which could be the anti-party core of
the particle why does the red ball leave
what what allows the the red ball to
leave if this area here is all full of
gravity pointing to the center of the
black hole these people are saying in
other words gravity stops at the event
horizon if you stand at the edge of the
event horizon you won't be sucked in
you're out of the gravity's range if you
take a step over you get sucked into the
singularity but as long as you don't
step over that line you're okay that's
nonsense
any star has an infinite radius to use
that term for gravity the earth pulls on
the moon a little outside our atmosphere
imagine if you were just standing out
our atmosphere and say well fortunately
you know gravity doesn't affect me
because I'm outside the range of gravity
that's what they're saying they're
saying that the red ball can escape
because there's no gravity there and so
we can just drift away that's nonsense
it should fall also into the black hole
there should be any radiation coming out
of black hole but otherwise but if they
did that all the astronomers would be
out of a job
so they had to create this nonsense
called Hawking radiation and now they
look for these sparks out there this is
a Hawking represented in his book you
can see the anti particle escaping to
infinity but gravity is not to infinity
just the particle escapes to infinity
right this is what they observed they
observe gases being sucked into
something or nothing whatever you want
to look at it so the gases of a star are
sucked in somehow and they said well
it's gotta be that black hole it's got
to be something there that's pulling it
in all this mass runaway gravity it's
pulling all that gasses okay we all
understand it we say okay sounds
reasonable
okay what else did they observe you
observe a star going around nothing in
circles server there's a telescope say
they take measurements they say this
star is moving quite fast it's moving
around nothing we don't see anything in
there now it could be you know some
other object that we can't see but they
say now it's got to be a black hole
because of the mass and you know it's
just this the star just goes around it
and so they yoga straighten it like that
they say that's what's happening
they're putting filling in the plants
are saying that black hole I'm gonna put
it in there so you can see why that
stars going around well but it's an
assumption it's an assumption based on
the fact that black holes might exist
there could be something called a black
hole well I can just put an angel that's
what I like to do I like angels you know
they're moving the star around and here
I have an angel sucking all the area in
there I mean yeah I can put anything
it's an assumption have I proven angels
no it's an assumption say let us assume
there are angels and if you concede my
assumption that I explained to you
anything and that's what they're doing
with a black hole so what are the
conclusions well it's an irrational
entity first because again we don't know
how many dimension it has we don't know
if it's a black ball or a region we
don't know what mass is they have never
defined the word mass the people will
argue for centuries with me mass and
weight are exactly the same thing and
when I say that people get so offended
at me but they've never been able to
isolate mass from weight why because we
measure them in the same way you want to
measure mass fact that's that's where we
had the yeah the master is kept of the
kilogram is kept in Paris and it's a
chunk of metal that weighs one kilogram
and we say that's one kilogram of mass
how do you know that weighs when did you
count all the atoms in there is it the
quantity of matter
no they waited they said this was gonna
be the kilogram so weight and mass are
the same thing because they have never
been able to isolate one from the other
they don't count atoms they don't count
particles of matter they measure and
when you measure when you weigh or
whatever do you're not you you know then
you can't distinguish mass from weight
and so these people have no definition
for for mass and no one has ever seen a
black hole but if you read any
popularization of the black hole you
will find always the same thing they've
proven it it's a done deal nothing to
argue and this is this is what should
make you stop and think that something
is wrong with mathematical physics okay
so this is what we got to answer we have
a star going around something or nothing
we have to answer what's happening here
this is
real thing that they're observing in the
sky we got it if it's not a black hole
it's not angels what is it we got to
answer this question scientists can't
avoid it and the same thing here if if
gas is being sucked into nothing how do
we explain this what's what's going on
out there in the sky in the night sky so
that's what I'm going to answer now I'm
gonna give you something again I haven't
come here to convince anyone came here
just to give you an alternative so you
can choose make up your own minds okay
when you're in high school you're taught
that the light is an electromagnetic
wave okay what is a wave well according
to niels bohr early part of the century
of the 20th century
he said the electron jumps back and
forth from the different energy levels
it drops to a lower energy level and
emits in quantum energy and when it
rises it absorbs a quantum of energy so
that's what you're seeing here that's
the quantum leap their quantum jump and
when it falls to an energy level it's a
wave it's a quantum of energy and that's
the wave that you see running out there
it's the electromagnetic wave and it's
made out of an electric field and a
magnetic field at 90 degrees to each
other okay
what are the problems with us with a set
up do with this thing that they teach us
in high school there's no such thing as
a wave wave is with something does a
flag waves but I can't say a wave waves
wave is what something does you can say
the water wave but you can't say the
wave waves what's the object that's
waving well they tell you there is no
object in the case of light and some
people say well it's the ether that's
waving and some people you know there's
a big fight on whether there is
something called an ether out there most
people believe there is no such thing
but the point is there's no such object
as a way wave is a verb it's not a it's
not a noun okay and they've turned it
into a noun in physics or in mathematics
really second the the wave is 2d each
one of the components the fields are
two-dimensional and there's a problem
with that because you have situations
like the photoelectric effect where
Einstein in fact showed that
the quantum packet is hitting an
electron and taking it out of its orbit
and causing electricity to flow if you
point a light to a shiny metal plate it
emits electricity there's a current
flowing and they're saying what's
hitting it is light and it's forcing the
the electron beads to flow from one atom
to another and that's the current well
we had a problem with that because then
if the wave is two-dimensional how does
it interact with three-dimensional
objects so we can't fit the
two-dimensional wave or the
two-dimensional fields in with three
dimensionality interaction that's where
the problem is orthogonality the
electric field goes 90 degrees to the
magnetic field why why would it in fact
when you're in high school or a college
they show you something like this I
don't see loosen it up right they go
they go up and down and they show you a
transverse wave a wave that moves up and
down perpendicular to the direction of
travel right they go do something like
that but there's two conditions first
this has to be tied if this is not tied
I can't produce that that's the first
issue
so in order to do this I got a tie one
end on one side and the other one I got
to hold on to then I can shake it say
this is not tired I can't do it then why
would the wave travel rectilinear why
does light travel in straight lines you
can't do it with the transverse wave and
why would the electric field travel
perpendicular to the magnetic field is
it just God just that's it and then we
have the problem where does the wave
begin and where does it end here you
have the Andromeda galaxy and you have
an atom emitting a wave to your eye
is it a little boat that travels or is
it an extended object that extends all
the way from there to your eye which is
true which is which is the correct
representation well they like to talk
about packets discrete packets they want
to show you that it's these little balls
that are coming to your eyes like a
machine gun shooting bullets at you but
that's what they illustrate they
illustrate continuous way where does it
the way begin does it begin here and end
there how long is a wave where do we
chop it off see the problem
so they talk about continuous on one
side and then talk about discreteness on
the other and emerged both into the wave
packet wave packet is both discrete and
continuous so again they cover all the
bases they call duality they say yeah
you got accepted it's both see we can
cover every base with this we got this
better than God you know we cover
everything and so what do they end up
with well this is the Penrose wave
packet this is science here now folks
please don't laugh well--that's Cupid's
arrow and got tangled with some
serpentine in there this is this is what
they illustrate for the way back what is
a way packet is it a wave continuous
waiver is it a packet of this green
packet it's both and of course when they
do it that way
it's very hard to challenge so what are
we replacing this was we're saying that
what they've been looking at all these
years is a rope now we can explain all
these features of light why is it
straight because the Rope is pulled
tight and I'll illustrate that here
they'll rope that I always bring if this
is pulled tight then you can imagine why
there's a straight axis now you can also
see why the electric field which we call
a thread it's a physical object field is
not a physical object goes at 90 degrees
to the magnetic field which is again a
thread there's two threads it's it's
what DNA imitated me and a imitated
light that's why we have all these
things like college and they're all
extended objects like a rope they're all
rope like features and here you can see
you know why it's a straight it's pulled
tight
and how do we produce light well we
torque it there's a torsion it's a
three-dimensional wave not a
two-dimensional up-and-down wave but a
torsion so now you have an atom in fact
I've Illustrated here in the next slide
you have an atom here's the rope now you
know why it's called the Rope hypothesis
by the way and you'll see it here the
two atoms are tied it it binds any two
atoms in the universe and the atoms are
vibrating they they expand and contract
their little balls of yarn you can think
of it that way when they expand they
twist the row
and now you have a torsion traveling to
the other atom when it extend it
contracts the same thing see the good
thing about a rope it goes both ways the
signal goes both ways well you can see
me and I can see you at the same time
like that it's because it's a rope
that's connecting these atoms not
something that I sent to you and you
send to me see the difference there
there's a difference in the concept here
that that we're trying to show there's
an equation that says C which is the
velocity of light is a constant it
always travels at 300,000 kilometers per
second why well see they will see you in
other words the velocity of light is
frequency times wavelength that's the F
and that's the lambda their frequency
times line their wavelength if you
increase the wavelength and you make it
longer you have smaller frequency and if
you increase the the frequency you if
you decrease the frequency you have to
have shorter wavelength and that's this
is the equation of a rope if you take
any rope right make sure you're real
quickly here I can tighten this many
times same amount of rope and now you
have more links per unit length I can
undo this and you can see what happens
now the lengths the links are longer but
you have fewer links that's frequency
times the wavelength in the model of the
rope this is the equation of a rope
that's why light travels at a constant
speed frequency can only do it at the
expense of wavelength a rope explains
this equation so what's the difference
quantum mechanics talks about discrete
particles and we're saying every atom in
the universe is interconnected they're
all connected to each other now we can
explain gravity for example for example
one thing that quantum mechanics are not
explaining is the force of pull how do
you pull with two particles how does one
particle put a line and others there's
no mediator you have to use angels you
have to use magic and here we're saying
that the atoms are interconnected there
is a rope there that's connecting them
we don't see the rope because you're
talking and you can't see atoms what's
us can you see oh this electromagnetic
rope because we're talking about
something so thin
you can't see it besides you wouldn't
need light to see light because that
yeah that is light see so people ask why
can't we see it you can't see it this
these are invisible threads are
connecting every atom in the universe
and that's the mechanism the medium
through which they send light they send
the torsion signal okay
we can explain gravity here we see the
Sun the earth and the moon they're all
connected now we can see why the moon
goes around the earth and the earth
around the Sun because they're all
connected why doesn't the moon fly away
they ain't never been able to explain
this they can explain with two objects
they can say we have a gravity well this
is what Einstein explained he says we
have a gravity well the sun weighs down
the canvas of space-time we don't know
why it weighs it down because you need
gravity for that but will concede that
okay so the Sun ways that do canvas down
the trampled in the your couch you know
you sit you you sink the the couch and
now the ball rolls around you fine no
problem why do we have third objects
that don't follow that if you look at
Uranus you know it weighs down the
canvas and it has its moon go around it
but it doesn't go around in the same
direction and goes over the poles why
would it do that Uranus would have to
weigh the canvas sideways and you have a
case of Pluto Pluto has Charon which is
it's its moon and faces the Sun like a
bull's-eye pattern like you're seeing
right now for me then Pluto would have
to push the canvas in my direction for
you to see that that bull's-eye pattern
in other words you can't do it with 3d
objects and they know the mathematicians
are well aware of this problem it's a
two object system the one that Einstein
explained he can't explain three objects
there's no way because you know you
would have to you know make it ad hoc
put it by finger because there's no
other way to explain it
you can't explain with math for sure
okay so we have a problem there okay so
what do we do with this well we're gonna
explain magnetism because I'm going to
show you that show you a different
version of this of what causes these
black hole phenomena I'm saying these
have to do with magnetism not with
gravity
nothing to do with gravity according to
the threat theory or the rope hypothesis
we take to any two atoms here right one
of the threads comes loose begin
swinging around the atom we take a row
of them we have a bunch of threads going
around each other now we have a wall of
threads going around now we can explain
electricity and magnetism current is
flowing upwards in here in this vision
and the magnetic field is going sideways
we've verified this in the lab everyday
the magnetic field travels perpendicular
to the electric field well here's a
visual representation of that using the
Rope hypothesis how do we explain
magnetism with this well we have these
threads the ones on the top moving in
one direction in a magnet and the ones
on the bottom moving the opposite
direction okay so you see the flow of
all the threads on the top part of a
magnet moving in one direction and the
other ones on the other side this can
explain why if we throw iron filings
over a magnet it gives you those
patterns your gym mat and pattern
because something is moving in there and
that's so-called magnetic field I can
show you this here if you put a magnet
into water and you have all these iron
Fighting's floating in there you will
see that over time hopefully you'll see
it there it collects all the iron
filings if nothing is moving there they
would just stay you know where they are
but something is movie something is
drawing these iron filings in something
is moving that magnetic field is
something in motion we're saying it's
the threads that are moving and
collecting all these iron filings and
keeping them close to the magnet how
does this produce attraction and
repulsion do we have to explain how a
magnet attracts another if we're gonna
explain magnetism well here we have a
vision of that we have two magnets
they're both facing in the same
direction we have north-south
north-south the tip the traditional
north-south north-south and the ones at
the top are all flowing clockwise the
ones on the bottom and they're flowing
counterclockwise so what happens as the
top ones from the first
it'd come down they collect the ones
from the top of the second magnet which
are coming up so we have this situation
okay and the ones on the bottom do
exactly yeah and so now a magnet
attracts another magnet and the closer
they are the more threads that intervene
the faster is the attraction and that's
what we verify in the lab so this is a
different mechanism that what you've
been taught in high school
repulsion we turn the magnet around and
now we have one clockwise the other one
counterclockwise now they're hitting
each other now they don't like each
other on the top and on the bottom so
now you can't put them together the
closer you have the more threads that
intervene the harder is to push them
together no particles just threads
moving around a magnet how does this
explain now black holes we get explained
now the black hole this is a galaxy when
we factor the magnetic field the
gazillions of threads coming out of
every atom that comprises the magnetic
field a galaxy has gazillions of stars
each one with gazillions of atoms a
bunch of those are excited and they
create the magnetic field of you know
the galaxy so the galaxy has a magnetic
field and each star in it has a magnetic
field also around it so each so you have
these little charged balls in this huge
humongous galaxy and both are charged so
how do we produce now these motions
these these fancy motions if you take a
charged ball in the lab you knew this in
the lab and you run it through a
magnetic field it turns into it turns in
circles now we can see why you know the
star would go around in circles around
nothing because that ball is going
around nothing we can do this in the lab
we don't need mass we don't need gravity
because it's not a gravitational
phenomenon I'm saying that what's
happening here is you have the magnetic
field of the entire galaxy in this case
it's sweeping through the center
downwards it doesn't matter
different galaxies depending on how you
look at them they could be upside down
whatever it is far as their magnetic
field and this is the effect you have a
field coming down
and it forces a charged particle we will
call charts ball it forces it to go
around the circles around nothing so
this is what you would observe you say
ho what's in the center why does the B
go around the flower because of the mass
of the flower no you know it's it's a
wrong conclusion and the area I see
Illustrated here you see the little
starts going around in circles this is
what we would observe through our
telescope we see there's nothing there
all we see is a star going around yeah
because the magnetic field is invisible
we don't see the magnetic field of the
galaxy what they do see from every
galaxy is the Jets they call them Jets
they think it's throwing plasma out of
the center again if it's a if every
galaxy has a black hole in the center it
would not be admitting anything it would
be swallowing everything in you wouldn't
see anything but they had to create the
Jets so they say it's Jets those famous
Jets that's the magnetic field going
around the galaxies and forcing charged
objects such as stars to go around in
circles I'm sure you you would not see
anything in the center of that you know
that circular motion and here we see a
magnetic field swallowing gases in this
case smoke this is a magnetic generator
and you can see how it's sucking up the
smoke what are the particles that we see
out there in space these gases a star
has suddenly all these gases coming out
of it they say where is it going well it
must be a black hole or an angel
whatever you know it's going in there
somewhere
well we're saying look it doesn't have
to be anything you know you can have in
this case I drew it this way you can
have the gases of a star being sucked
into nothing because it's all drawn by
the magnetic field of the galaxy so you
would not see an object swallowing it
just forces a star to lose the gases off
its surface okay so again all I'm trying
to show you is that there is a different
way to give explanations to these same
phenomena and you surely can't do it
with the the black hole because the
black hole has not been defined properly
we don't know how many dimensions that
have we don't know what it's made out of
and we've never seen one directly so
it's an assumption turned into a fact
I'm gonna go now briefly over
Dark Matter you've heard you hear about
this as much as you hear about black
holes dark matter is the latest craze
what is dark matter here's a here's our
solar system okay
mercury goes real fast around the Sun
Pluto takes with 248 years to go one
time around the Sun very slowly so here
we have this little planet close to the
Sun goes real fast and the one out here
goes very slow if you plotted you know
the speeds of each of the planets around
the Sun the orbits
that's the curve you would get you can
see that as the radius increases your
Batol velocity decreases okay so the
orbital velocity is always slower the
farther you get away from a planet
that's not what happens with a galaxy
it's called the galaxy rotation problem
galaxy has a different curve this is the
one we expected the one on the bottom
which resembles the one in our solar
system but that's the one we get the
farther you get the speed is is
increasing or staying the same and they
cannot explain this they say how can
this possibly be how can we get stars on
the outside of a galaxy to travel so
fast that they keep up with the ones on
the inside it's like the whole thing
rotates like a carousel you know the
buggies on the inside as fast as the
course is on the outside they all go at
the same time so to speak there it's not
exactly like that but think of it that
way what explanation you give for this
well they created a theory it's called
the dark kilogram theory the dark
kilogram theory says that you know if
you have to match the observed with a
predicted what you do is you put
kilograms in there and so they put
kilograms wherever they needed it they
said well we need it here if we put it
here in here in here then we can explain
this so they created this dark kilogram
theory your card the dark matter I like
the card the dark kilogram because have
you ever seen a kilogram what does it
look like well that's what dark matter
looks like like like a kilogram more or
less so they put this kilogram and say
well if we put it here then we can make
you go faster we don't put it here we
make it go slower so they just fit all
this dark matter wherever they needed it
it's an ad hoc invention they said we
can't explain
this is this is what we observe how do
you explain it with math now what what
equation can we use for this and so they
invented this variable called dark
matter and so they put it where they
needed to create that curve they need to
just you know explain the curve and they
can't explain it so they said well we're
gonna look for it but meanwhile this is
how this is the distribution and if you
look at a galaxy yeah they did it on the
outside usually it's on the outside of a
galaxy the question is why does in this
dark kilogram invisible nonsense exist
between the earth and the moon don't we
have kilograms here as well dark matter
between the earth and the moon and if we
did put it in there then all the
equations would be out of whack we
Newton Windward Einstein would work
nothing would work we can't put it
between the Earth and the moon any dark
matter because then you know we wouldn't
we wouldn't be able to use our equations
for for our rocks or whatever so they
poured it on the outside of a galaxy
it's always on the outside that helps us
explain the curve now they're looking
for it it's invisible it's translucent
it's dark it doesn't block out any stars
in the in the background but it exists
and we're looking for it and you're
paying for it
that's support that's important part I
gotta say that this is a web it's made
by a little spider here on earth and
that's what we're saying that we're
looking at all the stars in a galaxy are
interconnected we're gonna put this web
on top of a galaxy okay so we put it on
top of the galaxy what are we saying
we're saying all the stars are
interconnected now we can see why all
the weather the galaxy rotates at the
same time more or less like a carousel
because if every star is interconnected
and on top of that you have the magnetic
field giving more integrity to the
galaxy they don't even see how it all
rotates like a carousel we can explain
that part at least we don't need any
Dark Matter for this okay it's a simple
explanation in other words if every atom
in the universe is interconnected then
we can explain why galaxy rotates the
stars on the outside at the same speed
it to the one on the inside and finally
I'm gonna do a little bit of Big Bang
Big Bang is the moment of creation
without God there's no God here it's
just a self creation and what is the
problem with Big Bang the problem with
Big Bang is that how do you identify the
thing that was there before the
explosion happened what was there you
start out with what before you end up
with with with the universe how do you
create matter from nothing so we all
have a little bit of problem with that
right so they don't answer that question
but then they tell you that all these
universes that what these little cups
here's the here's the beginning right
and this is time we live in parallel
universes and they're all interconnected
by wormholes those are the little
curlicues you see there they're all
interconnected zero dimensional
entrances one-dimensional wormholes
right let's understand that I do there's
two dimension because I can't draw one
dimensional things yet so these
universes are interconnected by
wormholes the question is what is the
black stuff that separates all these
universe this contains space time and
matter in their space-time and man it's
all in there what's the black stuff that
it gives shape to space-time and to all
these space-time what is the wormhole
traversing to get to the other universe
what is that medium thought I mean I
don't know that's what they have to
answer these are the question what
physical medium contours right give
shape to space-time and how is matter
self-created I mean here we don't have
God even even God would have trouble
creating matter but without God I don't
know it's beyond my imagination so how
do you answer these questions how do you
answer what physical medium contours in
the end and how it's matter self-created
well here we had a couple of testimonies
one is from Hawking again from his
previous history of time it is
impossible to imagine a four-dimensional
space you you can't imagine you just
have to accept that on their word okay
in general relativity it became
meaningless to talk about space and time
outside the limits of the universe so
they're not gonna answer that question
what that black stuff is because it's
meaning it's a meaningless question they
say it's an unscientific question
because they can't prove to you with an
experiment what that black stuff is but
this is a conceptual issue they can't
start their presentation until they tell
me what that black stuff is
because they're going to run wormholes
through it they're going to separate all
these universes from one another with
this whatever thing is it is they have
to tell me what that black stuff isn't
to say that that's beyond the reach of
science it's a saying you know we're not
going to tell you about listen to our
theory you're gonna have to accept it on
the basis of authority questions such as
what is beyond the edge of the universe
or what is the universe expanding into
are as meaningless as asking what is
north of the North Pole now what is
north of the North Pole is the North
Star serious you know or some star out
there there there is a north of the
North Pole what is north of space or
space-time can we imagine you are we
talking about a ball and there's
something out here outside of outside of
our universe and then again what
separates our universe from the other we
have to answer these question we can't
just say well we can't answer that
that's a conceptual issue
and another fellow said such questions
as is the universe finite or infinite or
what caused the universe are false
cannot be answered because the point of
view from which such questions arises
does not really exist and is
unattainable in other words that don't
ever answer that question because
creation self creation is beyond words
it's it's got nothing to do with science
how do they we create stuff from nothing
well I already give you a little insight
earlier said you know you have
particle/anti-particle and that's more
or less what they how they explain the
creation of something out of nothing
space is made out of particles
anti-party going particle you separate
them and now you have particles which
before with space you put them together
you create nothing space okay
at the Big Bang itself the universe is
thought to have had zero size rate what
was outside of it we don't know in
quantum theory particles can be created
out of energy in the form of
particle/anti-particle pairs so now we
can create energy from that that means
we have something which is called energy
but that just raises the question where
the energy came from okay look at the
explanation the answer is that the total
energy of the universe is get exactly
zero why because we have positive energy
negative energy that's a mathematical
calculation that's minus E Plus egos
zero what does that have to do with
physics they're saying that we have zero
energy that's the starting point now we
separate positive from negative energy
we create matter we have at matter
antimatter and now for some reason we
ended up with matter which is us right
and the anti matter maybe went to
another universe I don't know you see
the problem these are all irrational
explanations we're not attacking the
math we're not saying you know the math
is wrong we're saying the explanations
of physical interpretations they give us
the physics part is absolute erat it's
not wrong it's not incorrect it's
irrational they cannot they say they
tell you we have a Richard Feynman he's
a 1965 Nobel Prize winner and he says no
one understands quantum mechanics that's
what he said 1965 by that time you know
quantum had been around for
5060 years Arthur Eddington guru of
mathematics of England he said there's
only essentially he said there's only
two people in the universe who
understand general relativity and he was
referring to Einstein and himself so
nobody understands these theories they
can't there's no way they cannot explain
them to you in a rational manner that
you would understand they say you want
to understand it you got to go to
college and learn math then you don't
understand it then you didn't you'll be
brainwashed in the right way it's
nonsense
it's all nonsense here's another
testimony this is from Brian Greene and
the fabric of the cosmos popular
documentary he says empty space is far
from empty in fact it is teeming with
activity particles constantly are
popping in and out of existence they
they erupt out of nothingness quickly
annihilate each other and disappear so
it's all magic
I caught mathematicians because it's all
magic what is this is this science this
is physics this means that they have the
wrong hypothesis they have the wrong
starting material and they have to cover
for that with these theories these
mechanisms the quantum mechanics empty
space is not that empty another from the
old Susskind it is full of fluctuating
fields full of sorts of jittery things
going on so this is the this is the
establishments version of how particles
get created from the void from nothing
from the vacuum and our particle
particle they separate and you put them
together you create nothing okay well
yeah we do it a little different in our
physics group we say physics base is
synonym of nothing what is nothing well
we have to define it we have to say
space that which has no shape that's
what space is nothing is that which has
no shape so something is that which I
say nothing is that which has no shape
they're in thesis there when is the
Conte the opposite of the other now we
can use these words consistently now I
can talk to you in a rational manner
when I talk space I'm talking about
nothing when I talk to you about an
object I talk to you about something
that has shape so space cannot
spontaneously acquire length width and
height all by itself and turn into a
physical object and an object cannot
spontaneously lose length with
I and become nothing now we can all
understand we can say look here we have
a something and it cannot lose length
width and height suddenly all of a
sudden you spontaneously and become
nothing
you know this becomes this nothing you
can't do that that's magic
that means I'm not gonna explain it to
you I'm not gonna explain to you the
process I'm just gonna tell you it is
and you get accepted and that's what
they're saying
so the conclusion matter has always been
there we've never created the universe
it's never gonna die or or disappear
matter has always been there matter
cannot drift past that which has no
boundaries if space is that which has no
shape there's no boundary to cross not
even God can escape that which is not a
medium and has no shape space is the
largest prison in ever built space is
nothing and we cannot convert something
into nothing nothing into something and
nothing cannot cross that which has no
boundaries now that now we can make
sense of this
there is no Big Bang that's it
you
you